>>> FOLLOWING THE BREAKING NS.
MAJOR RUSSIAN ATTACK ON KYIV.
ALEX MARQUADT IS ON THE SCENE IN
KYIV RIGHT NOW.
LOOKS LIKE THE SKIES ARE STILL
SHOWING THE RESULT OF THAT
ATTACK.
WHATEVER IT WAS.
BUT IT IS PRETTY ILLUMINATING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: IT IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
THIS HAPPENED ABOUT HALF AN HOUR
AGO HEARING THE LOUD STRIKE ON
THE AREA OF SOUTHWEST KYIV.
FOR THE PAST HALF HOUR YOU HAVE
SEEN THAT GLOW IN THE SKY.
REALLY BRIGHT RED.
IT IS A FIRE OF SOME SORT AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
TARGET MAY HAVE BEEN.
IT IS OVER NEAR TO AN AIRPORT.
WE KNOW THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
BEEN TARGETING MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS, THEY CLAIM THAT
THAT IS ALL THEY'RE TARGETING
BUT SAME TIME OVER NEAR WHERE
THAT FIRE IS NOW BURNING, THERE
WAS AN APARTMENT BUILDING THAT
WAS ALSO STRUCK TODAY THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ACCUSED THE RUSSIANS
OF HITTING WITH A MISSILE OR
WITH A ROCKET.
NOW, THIS COMES ABOUT 24 HOURS
AFTER PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WARNED
THAT LAST NIGH WOULD BE A
DECISIVE NIGHT, A DIFFICULT
NIGHT BUT IT PASSED WITH LITTLE
INTERRUPTION, RELATIVELY FEW
INCIDENTS.
BUT NOW THIS NIGHT IS SHAPING UP
TO BE A FAIR BIT WORSE.
I DON'T WANT TO JUMP TO ANY
CONCLUSIONS.
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD SO FAR ARE
LOUD TWO STRIKES FROM MY VANTAGE
POINT HERE IN THE CAPITAL OF
UKRAINE.
BUT SAME TIME IT IS THAT QUIET
FROM THE RUSSIANS THAT IS REALLY
QUITE DISCONCERTING.
AS JIM WAS SAYING A SHORT TIME
AGO THE ASSESSMENTS WERE THAT
RUSSIA COULD TAKE THIS CITY IN
24 TO 48 HOURS.
THEY CLEARLY DID NOT DO THAT.
WHY DID THEY NOT DO THAT?
FOR ONE THE UKRAINIANS WE KNOW
PUTTING UP RESISTANCE.
BUT NOW THERE COULD BE AN
INDICATION THAT THEY PLAN TO
STEP UP THEIR ASSAULT ON THIS
CAPITAL CITY.
WE KNOW OR IT IS PRESUMED FROM
THE INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENTS
THAT THEIR GOAL IS TO GET RID OF
THE ZELENSKYY GOVERNMENT,
INSTALL A GOVERNMENT THAT WAS
MUCH MORE SYMPATHETIC AND THEY
HAVE FACED SIGNIFICANT
RESISTANCE IN TRYING TO GET INTO
THIS CITY.
THAT MAY BE CHANGING NOW.
>> ALEX, STAND BY.
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
A DANGEROUS SITUATION IN KYIV.
MEANTIME ANALYSIS FROM THE
MILITARY ANALYST.
JAMES "SPIDER" MARX WITH ME.
YOU ARE OVER THERE WATCHING
THIS.
WHAT IS THE REACTION TO WHAT WE
SEE AND HEAR IN THIS CITY?
>> THANK YOU.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING UP
FRONT.
THE FORCES THAT ARE COMING INTO
KYIV ARE COMING IN IN THIS
DIRECTION.
IF YOU REALIZE THAT WHAT WE HAVE
HERE IS THE NIPER RIVER.
THE RUSSIANS DID NOT DEPLOY IN
THIS DIRECTION BECAUSE THERE
WOULD HAVE HAD A SEPARATION OF
FORCES SO WHAT WE SEE NOW IS
COMING INTO KYIV.
LET'S GO INTO KYIV.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT MORE
CLOSELY, HERE'S THE RIVER.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE IS
THAT THE RUSSIAN FORCES
ORIGINALLY UP HERE AT THE
AIRPORT.
KIND OF OUT OF THE CITY.
THEY'RE WORKING THE WAY INTO THE
CITY.
WHEN YOU COME INTO A CITY OF 3
MILLION THIS IS INCREDIBLY COME
PARTMENTALIZED.
THIS IS WHERE THE TERRAIN SUCKS
UP THE PERSONNEL.
WE ARE SEEING THE PREPARATION OF
THAT BATTLE SPACE WHICH IS NOT
GOING TO BE VERY PRECISE.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY BLOODY AND
VERY BROAD.
A LOT OF RUBBLE WILL BE CAUSED
AS A RESULT OF THIS INSERTION OF
ROCKET FIRE, MISSILE FIRE AND
PROBABLY SOME AIR FIRE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING ALSO IS
RUSSIANS DO NOT COMMAND THE AIR
SPACE WHICH IS A GOOD THING IN
PREPARATION OF THIS.
MOVING INTO THE CITY THE KEY
THING FOR THE UKRAINIANS AT THIS
POINT, NUMBER ONE, HOME FIELD
ADVANTAGE.
TERRAIN.
NEED TO MAKE CLEAR DECISIONS TO
START TO DROP THE BRIDGES ACROSS
THE RIVER.
IF THE RUSSIANS, ASSUME I'M
WRONG AND THEY HAVE FORCES HERE
THEY WOULD BE SEPARATED FROM THE
FORCES OVER THERE GIVING THE
UKRAINIANS A GREAT ADVANTAGE.
THERE'S A LOT OF FORCE TO COME
IN FROM THE RUSSIANS.
>> STAND BY.
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
WATCHING THIS SITUATION UNFOLD.
I WANT TO DISCUSS WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THE FORMER U.S.
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
JEH JOHNSON, ALSO WAS AN
OFFICIAL AT THE PENTAGON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE
MASSIVE EXPLOSIONS IN KYIV.
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE IN THE
COMING HOURS AS UKRAINIANS ARE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO HOLD ON TO
THEIR CAPITAL?
>> FIRST, I SALUTE YOUR
COLLEAGUES AT CNN ON THE FRONT
LINES IN KYIV.
BRINGING US INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THAT PART OF
THE WORLD.
THE ENTIRE FREE WORLD, WOLF,
RIGHT NOW IS ROOTINGING FOR
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, HIS
GOVERNMENT AND HIS PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE AND REPORTEDLY PUTTING
UP A STIFF RESISTANCE TO THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY IN THE INVASION
THERE.
THIS IS AN INSTANCE WHERE THE
WILL TO FIGHT EVEN WITH ONLY A
RIFLE OR A MOLLTIVE COCKTAIL TO
DEFEND FREEDOM, FAMILY AND
HOMELAND CAN OVERCOME A RUSSIAN
SOLDIER FOLLOWING ORDERS.
HAVING SAYING THAT I BELIEVE IT
GETS WORSE BEFORE BETTER.
I BELIEVE IT WILL BE BLOODY.
AMERICANS NEED TO PREPARE
THEMSELVES FOR SOME OF THE
IMAGES WE ARE GOING DO SEE OF
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES IN UKRAINE.
MANY AMERICANS WILL THEN ASK WHY
AREN'T WE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS?
WHY AREN'T WE GETTING INTO THIS
FIGHT?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
COME UNDER TREMENDOUS PRESSURE
TO INTERVENE DESPITE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S PLEDGE NOT TO PUT BOOTS
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE.
SO VERY SOON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION I PREDICT WILL
REACH A DECISION POINT WHAT TO
DO CONSISTENT WITH THE VALUES AS
AMERICANS.
WE HAVE IN THE PAST INTERVENE DS
TO DEFEND FREEDOM BUT WE NEED TO
REMIND OURSELVES IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS, WHETHER UKRAINE OR
LIBYA OR VIETNAM OR KOSOVO OR
AFGHANISTAN, IT IS MUCH EASIER
TO GET IN TO A SITUATION LIKE
THIS THAN IT IS TO EXTRACT
YOURSELF FROM A SITUATION LIKE
THIS.
>> THE FEAR IS IF THE U.S. OR
THE NATO ALLIES FOR THAT MATTER
WERE TO GET MILITARILY INVOLVED
WITH BOOTS ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE WITH ANTI-AIRCRAFT
MISSILES, WAR PLANES FLYING OVER
COULD LEAD TO A DIRECT WAR WITH
RUSSIA, A NUCLEAR POWER.
RIKT?
>> CORRECT.
WE HAVE MANAGED TO AVOID A
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA
THROUGH THE ENTIRE COLD WAR, THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS IN 1962.
WE SKILLFULLY MANEUVERED AROUND
A CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA.
AND IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL NOW WE
COULD FIND OURSELVES IN EXACTLY
THAT.
SO OVER THE NEXT DAYS, WEEKS IT
IS GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
DISCIPLINE AND DELIBERATE
THINKING ON THE PART OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS CABINET
TO AVOID A DIRECT CONFRONTATION
WITH RUSSIA AS THEY HAVE PLEDGED
TO TRY TO AVOID.
>> IT'S SUCH A DANGEROUS
SITUATION RIGHT NOW AND